he was one of the impeachment managers
now Congressman you know what I think of
Alejandro my orcus right I've been I've
been hammering him since uh January of
2021 but but explain to the angle
viewers what the point was in doing this
given the razor thin numbers that you
had especially because the real culprit
isn't the real culprit Joe Biden not my
orcus who's just the you know he's just
the hired help
well Lor two things about that we can
say Joe Biden should be impeached and
maybe that's where we should go but I
can tell you this Alejandra mayorca as
early as 2021 issued a memorandum where
he iterated what his proposals were for
the border and those were basically to
open the Border disobey title 8 of the
law where he was going to then uh change
how you did everything from remove
people um he was not going to allow them
to remove people he was not following
the law and so impeachment was designed
um literally since
1450 the year 1450 was to remove
somebody from Office who is going to do
irreparable harm or potential Dam damage
to the community or the state and that's
what Alejandra maror was is doing he's
continuing to do it and that's why we
felt I feel it's like our duty to
actually try to remove this guy because
I think he is a danger and I think what
he's doing is causing irreparable harm
and thus our duty is to go forward and
if you're not successful uh then then
that's that's not okay I mean I'd rather
be successful but you have to fight the
fight or else there's no point in you
being here trying to do what's right
well let's say let's say he had been
impeached and you actually had a
Republican Senate and you could remove
him and convict him and remove him from
office would you think that Biden would
put in someone that you and I I would
like in that position it wouldn't it be
like a game of whack-a-mole we have the
next Alejandra my
orcus everything with this
Administration is like whacka mole uh
for sure and yeah he they could appoint
somebody else and nominate them but the
Senate then could not accept that
confirmation you'd get somebody's
temporary there and part of the
impeachment process is to uh hold people
accountable and Alejandra mayorcas needs
to be held accountable now on your other
point though I do believe that one of
our strongest uh checks against an
executive who has gone bad which I think
this Administration has particularly on
this issue is to use the checkbook and
so I've been arguing literally for
several years to reduce the funding for
many of the of this administration's
programs until they actually enforce the
border so I do think impeachments
necessary and required it's our duty but
I also think there's other ways to get
at this cat as well and one of those is
to actually say no more money for I
don't know how about the FBI uh new
headquarters how about the IRA Green New
Deal stuff let's stop funding that stuff
until we can get uh confirmation that
they're going to enforce the Border yeah
well if a phone call uh a phone call was
zinsky was an impeachable offense what
Biden has done to the US border and to
our country causing death and
destruction should be an impeachable
offense I think Biden is impeachable
here Congressman thank you so much for
joining us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else